and I'm pleased to say joining me to
debate all this this evening is social
media influencer Ollie London a man who
is in the process of de-transitioning
from a trans woman back to a man
and also by veteran lgbtq activist Peter
tatchell and comedian and radio
presenter James Barr familiar face on
this show as well also joining us down
the line Bev Jackson co-founder of LGB
Alliance which promotes the rights of
lesbians bisexuals and gay men Bev thank
you ever so much we're going to start in
the studio I want to come to
all of you join me here you heard what I
just said there Peter coming to you
first
am I over egging it by saying I'm not
allowed to talk about this because I'm a
straight woman
I think you're entitled to your point of
view but obviously please listen to what
LGBT plus people are saying
um on this particular issue it is very
clear there are more than a thousand
LGBT plus organizations in the UK mostly
LGBT lesbian gay and bisexual and almost
without exception they support including
trans people within our Coalition and
trans people have been here right from
the beginning they were outside the
Stonewall in protesting in 1969 which
saw the birth of the modern there's been
a Gay Liberation movement they were also
in the London Gay Liberation Front in
1970 and 71 when we began all that half
century and more ago so trans people
have always been part of our community
and we think we should all stick
together united we stand divided before
the James Community nodding along there
is
then is it spirit
s there are these arguments happening
that there are divisions or strange yeah
absolutely I completely disagree with
what you were saying I don't think there
are divisions or strains within our
community I think there's a small
faction of people outside of the
community who want to create a moral
Panic about trans people for no reason
other than the fact that they are hiding
behind that to push forwards their
right-wing agenda and actually it
disgusts me because you know we have a
lot of Rights in this country as lgbtq
plus people it's outrageous to suggest
that we close the door behind us and
stop trans people getting through as
well now what about sort of thoughts
when I was approaching this show this
evening was that we didn't have a trans
person who is remaining trans coming to
be part of this debate so I've heard
from you both on this but obviously
Ollie you have are in the process
detransitioning from trans so I don't
know whether the trans Community will
feel they have I think I just want to
interrupt and Ollie You can disagree but
is it not right to say that you're
de-transitioning from being transracial
not transgender
transgender how long were you
transgender for a year because I'd argue
that if you were a transgender woman
you're therefore a woman and if you're
saying you're not transgender now
therefore you were never transgender no
I struggled with uh my identity my whole
life and you know it's the trans
Community they're always saying oh you
shouldn't question someone if they feel
trans if that's how they identify you're
not allowed to question them so why
because ID transition why would you
question I'm not questioning that I
don't I'm sorry that you went through
that but that doesn't mean that everyone
has the same experience as you correct
everybody has a different in spirits and
they're entitled to that but my issue is
the trans activists that have hijacked
the LGBT community and are causing real
harm to the LGBT community by pushing
gender ideology on children by forcing
women out of women's spaces that is my
issue I don't have an issue of trans
people I have many trans friends my
issue is with the radical gender
ideology so do you think there is case
for the argument then that this show is
premised around this evening that there
is a bit of strain in the community
there's definitely strain I mean look
there are people that say that sexuality
and gender identity should not be
conflated and I think the real issue is
the more extreme elements of the trans
activists that are pushing this agenda
are pushing for all these things on
children pushing for hormones on kids
and puberty blockers that's the real
life again if you spend like 75 000
pounds on surgery to look like a member
yes so should we not be talking about
BTS indoctrinating but then you can say
the same about someone that's non-binary
you know you could say are they not
allowed to identify as how they feel
that's all I was doing
the same logic I'm using the same logic
as woke people you can identify as
anywhere lgbtqi plus 2s two Spirits if
someone money can identify as two spirit
I can choose whatever I want I was
struggling my identity I've dealt with
those issues and now I'm trying to help
children the LGBT community should be
coming together to help children to find
a solution to support trans people as
well people that have struggled their
whole life but in your job I support
that but we also need to respect women
men shouldn't be in women's faces men
shouldn't be in women's sports we need
to respect all people I'm going to come
to Bev now because uh Bev has also been
kind enough to join us to see if you've
been listening to that hope you heard
all of it Bev
um yeah go ahead interest yeah yeah
happy too happy to join in this
discussion uh I'd like to respond to a
few of the things but first I think I
should clear up that the title is
perhaps a little bit um uh misleading I
think this is not a question about the
LGB dropping the T but why the tea was
added to LGB in the first place and
people perhaps think that it's always
been there but in fact in the UK it was
only added in 2015 and
um that no lesbians were consulted the
time the consultation was all with trans
groups and I think you would have found
that lesbians would have been very
unhappy in fact many lesbians were
unhappy when they discovered that the
tea was added LGB is about relationships
it's about love it's about sex it's
about who you're attracted to are you
attracted to men are you attracted to
women or are you attracted to both it's
very clear sexual orientation tea and Q
and all the other letters that have been
added since then are about identity
issues they're completely separate and
it's caused a lot of confusion we've
seen um how much confusion it's caused
with labor politicians trying the
desperately to avoid saying what a woman
is and that's quite comic but it's also
caused a lot of tragedy particularly for
lesbians it's no a coincidence that LGB
Alliance was founded by Kate Harris and
me two lesbians and our CEO is a lesbian
and also the chair of the board is a
lesbian it's lesbians who have suffered
from the addition of the tea
um to LGB and I think your subtitle
perhaps should be reading campaigners
argue that the gay community has been
hijacked but anyway so what has happened
with uh with lesbians let me explain why
I'm saying that it's a tragedy for
lesbians what we're seeing at the moment
and you can look that thousands hundreds
of thousands of lesbians are um having
their breasts removed you can see tens
of thousands
um fundraising on GoFundMe to have their
breasts removed and um this is because
it's no longer cool to be lesbian in
fact I spoke to a 19 year old recently
who said that throughout her Secondary
School she'd been told she must be a boy
she'd must be a boy because she fell for
girls this is the kind of homophobia
that is being taught at schools taught
online and spread online and spread by
peers so that lesbians don't feel
comfortable about being lesbian anymore
this kind of homophobia is is a real
tragedy and in fact the fact that it is
being propagated it I think it calls for
a public inquiry how is it possible ten
years ago you would have been thought a
bit weird if you'd said that men can can
change into women and women can change
it to men and these days You're called
weird If you deny it the fact is you
can't change sex children shouldn't be
taught that they they can change sex
it's like teaching them yeah they can
fly they might jump out of the window
and find they can't fly and they can't
change so many you've brought up a lot
of points there I'm gonna say and that
is the kind of the issue with this
conversation as a whole because we're
talking about so many different types of
people I mean in and of itself I find it
fascinating that I'm talking about
lesbians you're talking about the the
examples that Bev and Ollie give are
totally unrepresentative yes they happen
and I condemn them but they're not
representative Britain's biggest lesbian
celebration lesbian visibility week
which took place in April was inclusive
of trans and non-binary woman it was
celebrated by lesbians lesbians
themselves wanted trans and non-binary
people to be part of of this celebration
I listened to you without interruption
can you please show courtesy be polite
and courteous
um you know those lesbian women who are
behind lesbian visibility week they
included trans and non-binary people
with the support of The Wider lesbian
Community there's a small number of
lesbians who disagree with this trend I
accept that they're entitled to their
point of view but they're not
representative of the wider lesbian
Community I want to come to James now
you wanted to jump in Bev we will come
back to you we will come back to bed but
we'll just go to the studio James you
wanted to jump in I was like no I'm and
I just broadly have a question do you
find this conversation is gonna
obviously we're not gonna find a
solution or resolution but is it useful
to talk about no it's not I actually
find it incredibly boring and I think
the stuff that Bev is spouting is
transphobia and I genuinely believe that
it's it's kind of amusing that you're
talking about uh homophobia because
really you're just being transphobic and
those two things don't cancel each other
out they are not helpful at all and
you're talking about children being
indoctrinated it's Insanity it's
literally not happening there's no proof
of that happening um Ollie
why are you bringing up conversations
like that when you have not had that
yourself I mean can only not speak to
his personal experience well his
personal experience he's literally
wanting to look like an Asian this is
this is a great but we're not talking
about banning BTS sorry I'm not allowed
to speak this is a great example of woke
people you do you shout people thank you
you don't give people you know talking
of inclusivity what about including
women in this conversation what about
including women in women are included in
this college
is here suggesting that she supports let
me speak trans activists are constantly
pushing at women just yesterday at the
Oxford Union a trans activist blew
themselves to the floor because they
didn't want the woman to speak about
women's rights is that fair do you think
it's fair that women aren't allowed to
have a conversation that their movement
is just suddenly hijacked they can't do
Sports they're scared to speak up
athletes are scared to speak up in case
they're deemed transphobic for saying
the simple fact that biological men have
a competitive advantage we know that so
let's let women speak let's stop going
on about what transactions letting women
speak let's let's get out to Bev go on
then Bev
yeah I I want to say that that
um first of all we tried very hard to do
context and well when they changed uh
and when Stonewall changed all the other
uh um organizations that have been uh
gay rights groups around the country all
changed to focus on gender identity and
uh we tried to get them to to discuss
the problems but they wouldn't we
eventually had to form LGB Alliance
which goes back to the roots of standing
up for sexual orientation the second we
formed LGB Alliance people and you can
listen please listen to this we were
deluged by messages from lesbians all
over the world thank God you're here I
have felt so isolated thank God when are
you setting up in Canada when are you
setting up in Australia thank God can I
what can I do to help and the reason
that we were able to grow so quickly we
were just two women two old dikes yes we
had no money we had no external funding
and all these this nonsense about right
funding it's complete nonsense we were
two women who worked our asses off seven
days a week 16 hours a day and all for
all these lesbians who contacted us and
they joined us and we built a wonderful
organization of some of the the clever a
chance to respond people in the world
Bev you and I were both in the Gay
Liberation Front in the early 1970s and
as you well know from among the Gay
Liberation for activists were trans
women like Carla and Rachel
they were prominent now movement they
were featured in the gay uh the come
together newspaper it was part of our
wider movement and just as we challenged
premises that refused to serve lesbian
gay and bisexual people we also had a
very famous sit-in at a cafe in pivoli
Circus which refused to serve trans
people we saw these two different
struggles as being different but also
having communality the common experience
of prejudice discrimination and we
should stay together now we should stand
up for each other and not divide yeah
I'm very sorry
I need to ask Peter if he's read Stuart
feathers book blowing the lid you can
ask Peter that on the DMS after the show
unfortunately we are fresh we should
read it we are fresh out of time look we
really appreciate you joining the
conversation this evening and to our
panelists in the studios well I've been
fascinated by this especially on the Eid
of private talking about the division
but hopefully a bit more Unity it's been
great to have all your insights thanks
so much for your time thank you